Secret number one to writing viral
hooks, inject curiosity by adding a
twist. Let me give you an example.
Here's a headline that says, "What the
Bible says about money." Okay, headline.
And by adding a single word, we're going
to make it infinitely more curious.
Watch this. What the Bible actually says
about money. Increase the curiosity.
Increase the clicks. Increase the
attention. Here's another one. How to
write $1,000 emails. Interesting. Now,
let's add a twist. How to write thousand
emails in 10 minutes. Always look for
some way to add an extra layer of
intrigue to your headlines to increase
the curiosity, which increases the
clicks and attention. If you missed it,
here it is